[Music]
in worst criminal ever news oh I love
these submitted by hi from New York
hello love you Pete says a thief stole a
woman's car from a parking lot and then
called her for advice on how to start it
maybe she didn't hear one of those cars
with those this is my phone or something
yeah so I had the exact same question
and they don't let see as to how he
called her that may be quiet pretty rude
very rudeness
yeah so I'm guessing it's the same thing
too yeah maybe some more he knows or
something [ __ ] up he doesn't know tax
or card hmm yeah so this took place in
Minneapolis have you kind of pissed too
if I sold the car and it started [ __ ]
up on me I'll be like yo lady dude
when's the last time you had an oil
change [ __ ] like a more reliable cars
lady it's like hey I'm selling your car
yeah once last time you had repairs done
because this guy's haggling me the spark
plug to new did you have like records
he's let me in your car they're
responsible are you I mean you know
you're supposed to change the belt every
100,000 miles like what the hell or like
your car's messy and so he's pigsty in
here no water balls of [ __ ] that's
Nicki's Carmen this woman crunch every
time I get in that car
oh hey because I get in the car and
there's like 17,000 like oh these water
bottles on the ground I go I picture
like a recycling plant in her under the
bus dude she belongs there for the
things that she does she belongs there
she never brought you up once because
she wasn't thinking about you she was
just worried about the article and she
was just pushing her own funny she's
she's bringing up one timing no not once
one time and I get once no heard she
does she like a peed my pants for
nothing
she should have
came on her so anyway so the woman the
owner of the car she wasn't shopping at
Walmart and from inside of Walmart she
started her car like the auto start
thing Oh up her car but by the time she
walked out her car was gone because cold
place Oh Minnesota boy that's the
coolest place like right now yeah in
America's ok so this was about 8:35 p.m.
and at 10:30 p.m. the owner received a
call from the man who stole the car
his name was Edward Leroy Wilson he's 37
years old did you guys on that three
first names yeah oh yeah suspect yeah so
then Edward called her saying that he
was claiming to work for a glass repair
shop and that he had taken the the Jeep
Grand Cherokee and to get work done but
then after he parked it the Jeep
wouldn't start again since he didn't
have a key all right so then he told her
to call someone to get the car running
so he could return the car to her but
then obviously what she did is just yeah
he's like whatever you do don't call the
police because this is a glass repair
shop matter yeah Edward what's his name
Leroy Wilson yeah
no is it
I guess the Leroy has Lee in it that's
cool
yes and who's a barber is he adopted or
did he take his wife's name I have no
idea
that's the lien that he the crazy and
why does he gotta look at me that way
like he looks like he's about to murder
people
you know his bottom why they look crazy
he's been crying water line yeah their
coffee bro a lot of sleep where was this
at Minnesota Minneapolis Minneapolis
Minneapolis huh betcha he's mom and his
mom mom mhm yes [ __ ] something Leroy
Wilson yeah Edward Edward Leroy Wilson
interesting so he apparently told the
police that he knew it was not a good
idea to get in the vehicle that's it
that's it he wouldn't even go with his
original excuse you have some excuse I
got in the wrong car and then I left and
by the time that I like realized exactly
like my [ __ ] car oh great where are
your cars so but he's still my car right
exactly
I've actually done that before you got
in too much soil I didn't get in their
car but I kept trying like to unlock in
like what the [ __ ] is going on and I was
getting pissed on my [ __ ] I'm checking
have to use the key and I'm like jamming
my key in there and like turn it I'm
like what the [ __ ] and then I'm like
looking around like well how does it
happen like I'm gonna look for help I'm
like oh [ __ ] my car's okay man this
one's got my stereotyped meter off
[ __ ] up already it's all [ __ ] up how
am I gonna judge him without knowing him
now yeah I mean first off he doesn't
look like a Edward Wilson and when I
hear that name it's ambiguously black or
white yeah her name is Joe I know but
the last name is Jason Kawa okay sure I
get it away so like he look I mean he
could have been like a Edward Lee you
know like that that just doesn't make
sense and then the the crime that he's
doing it's not an Asian crime
what's in it oh yeah I know it's not an
agent
it's a crack cake what about triads in
student cars not like this not waiting
for people to come out of Walmart
jumping into cars
well what's the agent about triads by
the way where they called triads are not
gangs I have Noi's just an organization
yeah the way the organized it's a sick
sounding name it is triad I mean like
because Asia's like math and isn't a
trial [ __ ] joke that is the algebra
way to say it's a game I think there's
like three heads or maybe three branches
that form one big unison being I don't
know it's [ __ ] golden do you guys
oughta start your cars before you cool
it up David would end up in this story
like this because David's done so many
stupid things where he went to the
barber got his hair cut never once
turned off the car do y'all warm up your
cars no mmm not in California I don't
think we ever need a warm-up well tell
that to to Nikki she warms up well she
gets real cold why are you looking at me
I'm not Nikki with I'm chucking her back
down to the bus yeah for cold there you
go see
car again burn I'm going again surprise
it unlocks your doors though like when
you oughta start it like I would imagine
like it that's she unlocked it - yeah
she was walking toward the car she might
she might have like a ton of [ __ ] she's
like I remind her to start unlocking oh
well my buddy my buddy has that but he
does it because he lives in Salt Lake
where it's cold as [ __ ] like in the
wintertime and so he does it to make it
that make sense yeah why do people want
to live in a Tundra for this just
doesn't make any damn sense he's cheaper
but Oh a cheaper see I appealed to him
see how would I mind though I like to
call I wish it snowed here no no no I'd
like it technically but one man when
you're there it sucks like I was just in
Park City for this movie thing we were
doing and it was so cold that I was like
I can't live out here anymore
I like the feeling of being cold and
running into a house and then running
into
the building and just like it always
when you're outside it feels so
uncomfortable and you can't wait to find
some places going so that's how you get
pneumonia
do you like anything like relaxing and
soft and Flowery
yeah that's why I like the cold because
then you could drink hot cocoa and rest
by the fireplace but then you're gonna
complain how hot it is in your normal
run outside again yeah but you have
option C get the juice
that's true dude there were people cheer
in the middle it was like seriously
eight below in Park City and they're in
the hot tub cats in the hot tub then
when you're getting out that's terrible
it's really close this you just have to
calculate you have to make sure that the
hot tub is right next to the door if
it's not all learning in your body gets
so warmed up that it becomes invincible
for five minutes
well that's pretty you just gotta make a
trail of towels that you could walk on
the coping a red carpet yeah towel club
you gotta do it you gotta do it okay I
think when you're thinking about the
cold it's all the fun stuff
yeah and then when people say they don't
like the snow and cold it's cuz like
shoveling their driveways yeah and in
the salty cars and all the [ __ ] that
goes down it messes up your car yeah you
can't you're snowed in you can't go out
you don't have freedom yeah you have to
like you have to I mean I remember we
used to dig my dad's car out when we
lived in Virginia before he go to work
because there's so much snow and [ __ ]
everything is like just snowed I've
never seen that Emily feel like the
closest thing to that is Big Bear and
Baker was amazing two years back those
guys crazy got the right time that way
you're describing it was like that it
was like a wonderland I see cars driving
away with like this much of snow on the
roof and there's so much snow that some
cars just completely disappear on the
block and what you're describing is
called it's called tourists mentality
we're like wouldn't it be great if and
then when you're there and you're living
in it like all [ __ ] it's like it's like
what you go you go to like we're in Bali
and it's like wouldn't it be great to go
live up in the mountains with the
mountain people and there and there it
looks it's not they don't like it
they don't want to be there they live in
my hunts they don't like it they wish
they have to post me so you wish they
had toilet paper yeah exactly
don't like wouldn't it be romantic visit
it yeah then we just go to Big Bear I
love big big weirdo man you can get the
rent the dopest cabins for like not much
at all - yeah it's awesome
I saw that in Japan like when I got
there it wasn't there wasn't any snow
and then the next day it was like winter
wonderland and yeah and then we were
like eating breakfast and they had this
huge [ __ ] like glass overlooking like
this pond and then there was like ice on
the little island and it was really a
big deal with like the logistics of like
moving all the snow are they really
efficient with that - like I wasn't
watching but I'm sure cuz when I looked
at the road it was all cleared out yeah
I was it Park City
they did they do three plows in a row
and they're just constantly going in a
loop like up and down the freeways and
all that stuff and just just clearing
out all the snow but they do it in a row
so it's like one plow one sweep away and
they're all driving like in sync and
it's it's dope to see because you see
waves of snow just getting to Capetown
Stowe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]